we've talked a lot about net neutrality
we've talked a lot about Donald Trump
and net neutrality we've talked a lot
about how independent non corporate news
like the David Pakman show and so many
other shows depend on a free and open
Internet in order to exist and succeed
Donald Trump clearly doesn't understand
much of what net neutrality is but he is
against it and that is sort of the theme
of the Trump campaign Trump of making
very strong declarations about things he
knows very little about Donald Trump on
net neutrality at once said that Obama's
attack on the Internet is a top-down
power grab that net neutrality is the
Fairness Doctrine and it will target
conservative media so clearly Trump has
no idea what net neutrality is but that
doesn't matter and we've now heard from
the FCC's two Republican members they
spoke through Internet service providers
two days ago and told them that they're
going to get to work on destroying net
neutrality rules quote as soon as
possible I'm talking about none other
than Ajit PI and Michael O'Reilly they
sent a letter to five lobby groups that
represent a bunch of different wireless
carriers ISPs of different sizes and
they are saying soon after Trump is
inaugurated we're going to try to get
that net neutrality nonsense destroyed
here is a quote from their letter and it
is just disgusting quote we note that
the new requirements are not in effect
and not enforceable until January 17 of
2017 we want to assure you and your
members that we would not support any
adverse actions against small business
providers for supposed non-compliance
with the enhanced transparency rules
after that date and we will seek to
revisit those particular requirements
and the title to net neutrality
proceeding more broadly as soon as
possible so what is this a wink and a
nod about from the Republican FCC
members number one they're saying listen
the rules start January 17 and after
that point we have no interest in
punishing anybody for not following them
and we're going to try to change those
rules as soon as possible for you
there's a really important keyword in
there they talk about small businesses
we don't support actions against small
businesses this is a complete and total
ruse which has been created to give the
impression that net neutrality hurts
small businesses and small ISPs the
reality is that destroying net
neutrality is a way to help ISPs and
major businesses stand to gain millions
upon millions of dollars and it's a
trick they are trying to trick people
yes this doesn't affect small businesses
this affects large media conglomerates
and I would love to hear Donald Trump
articulate his position on net
neutrality oh yeah we didn't hear any of
that during the debates no we heard he's
against it we heard it's bad he's
against that in he's against anything
Obama has done the way in which small
businesses are being sort of used as a
ploy to convince people about how bad
net neutrality is reminds me of the
cigarette Lobby the cigarette Lobby
funded by major major big tobacco
started going through small bars and
restaurants I believe it was mostly in
the 70s although it may have been even
earlier than that they would show up at
bars and restaurants and they would say
hey listen smoking bans that the local
legislature is trying to pass those are
really bad for you because if people
can't come to your restaurant or your
bar and smoke they're going to go
elsewhere it's gonna be really bad for
you no it turned out it was bogus if you
can't smoke in any bars or restaurants
people still go they either smoke before
after or step outside during we figure
that out the reality was it was framed
as helping small business to keep
smoking bans out it was actually all a
ploy to help big tobacco and this is the
exact same thing that I believe is going
on here with net neutrality this is one
where you can activate you can contact
your representatives about this if we
already had our progressive engagement
coordinator in place they would be
coordinating an effort across
progressive media because there are a
few issues more important than net
neutrality two independent progressive
media for now you can go to Senate gov
slash senator slash contact to contact
your Senators about this you can go to
house.gov slash representatives slash
find to contact your congressional
representative about
and by the way donate to the campaign
we've got going on at david pakman.com
slash donate this is an issue that no
matter what happens over the next four
years in terms of specific cabinet picks
or specific direction that we see the
Republican Party going the attacks on
net neutrality are going to continue and
we have to be prepared to fight back
thanks for watching this video before
you watch the next one
remember we're raising money to expand
the David Pakman show big league as well
as expand progressive activism go to
david pakman.com slash donate donations
of any size are much appreciated